the gun fetishist right wing is in a
tizzy
after retired Supreme Court Justice John
Paul Stevens proposed that activists
currently activating for gun safety
should be pushing not for background
checks or for an increased age limit on
gun ownership but that they should be
pushing for a full repeal of the Second
Amendment and John Paul Stevens wrote
this in a New York Times op-ed yesterday
and after realizing many right-wingers
that the op-ed was written not by Led
Zeppelin bassist John Paul Jones but
rather by 97 year old retired Supreme
Court Justice John Paul Stevens they
went bonkers calling for his head and
his point was the demands that the
students who have been activating that
the protesters that who have been
activating recently that wave of demands
which includes good demands right
restricting access to some weapons
increasing the gun buying age to 21
background checks all that stuff he says
that that's all fine well and good but
he is taking the approach of encouraging
protesters to campaign for the outright
repeal of the Second Amendment to the
Constitution he believes that if we were
able to get rid of that second amendment
that we would be set up on sort of the
best and most effective path forward
when it comes to gun violence and not
surprisingly there's people on the left
and right that are frustrated with him
obviously the gun fetishist right is
straight up calling this treasonous but
there's even people on the Left who are
taking positions that either a second
amendment repeal goes too far like there
are many people on the Left who are gun
owners and believe that we have a Second
Amendment and regulation is okay
background checks etc but that the
Second Amendment should stay or there is
also an approach from the left which I
am more sympathetic to which is that
this is a very unproductive suggestion
from the retired Supreme Court justice
because it just won't work and I happen
to agree with that
I believe that focusing on a repeal of
the Second Amendment is a mistake in its
sheer impracticality you will get more
done by reforming the system that we
have and you will lose people and
probably create more enemies to your
cause if you jump to
let's repeal the Second Amendment and
I'm not coming at this from a
constitutional originalist point of view
if you've been watching the show
listening to this program for any length
of time you know that I believe that
there's no possible way that a document
written in the 18th century and then
amended a couple of dozen times years
and years ago could be fully relevant in
2018
I believe in continuing to make changes
and in sort of modern interpretations of
the Constitution so I'm not coming at it
from that point of view I hate that guns
are this much a part of our culture but
they are and with the number of guns
that are out there with the opposition
that you would create by making a repeal
of the Second Amendment your agenda I
think it's just a losing approach and
there's sort of two approaches to
achieving big change in politics big
picture right one approaches the Ted
Kennedy approach the incremental
approach which is any small step you can
take in the direction you want you
should take and over time a lot of small
steps will add up to bigger change
that's one approach the other approach
is you've got to start with the most not
extreme but the the the most radical
position the most changing position and
negotiate to the middle I don't think
that one strategy is right for all
issues health care for example I think
the left should start the conversation
at something far more progressive than
slight tweaks to Obamacare and this was
a criticism of President Obama when he
negotiated Obamacare which is he should
have started with something much more to
the left to end up negotiating to a more
progressive middle we can debate whether
that's an accurate criticism or not but
I believe on health care there's value
to taking a more left position to begin
with on the gun issue going to the
Second Amendment repeal is going to make
you so many enemies that you're going to
end up hurting your own cause and you'll
end up hurting the entire left I believe
there are we talk about gun rights being
a voting issue versus a non voting issue
I believe that to the extent that the
left wants
background checks or changing the gun
buying age or restricting access to
certain weapons I think in a lot of the
country it's not a voting issue for most
voters if the position becomes repealed
the Second Amendment I think you're
gonna lose a lot of people because it
will become a voting issue so that's the
pragmatic part let's now get to the
political strategy part repealing the
Second Amendment actually wouldn't be
that big of a deal
right there's lots of countries without
constitutionally guaranteed access to
guns that still have gun ownership right
it's restricted to responsible adults
there's different processes and
restrictions in different countries but
not having constitutionally guaranteed
access to guns doesn't mean you have a
tyrannical government that creates a gun
grabbing dystopia now since we have a
Second Amendment in the United States
it'd be pretty difficult to get rid of
it because you'd need two-thirds of both
houses of Congress the House and Senate
to vote to do it and you'd need
three-quarters of the states also I mean
just forget it right so send me your
thoughts on this what I'm most
interested in is whether this is even a
productive discussion to be having like
is there really any value for the left
to talk about whether the position
should be to repeal the Second Amendment
I believe that the answer is no on this
particular issue if you think I'm wrong
just let me know why I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by
brilliant which is really a fantastic
and unique online service that has sort
of reinvented the way people learn math
and science if you watch the show
you're already probably generally
curious about how the world works and
you like to learn new things maybe you
have a sort of casual interest in
physics or solar energy or AI philosophy
computer science but you're ready to
take it to the next level and whether
you already have a grasp on these
subjects or you want to engage and
acquaint yourself with these topics for
the first time brilliant is the place to
go you can actually learn hands-on by
solving problems and puzzles that were
designed by expert
educators and professionals and you can
start right now sign up for free at
brilliant org slash David Pakman the
first 200 people who visit brilliant org
slash David Pakman will get 20% off an
annual premium membership that is
brilliant org forward slash David Pakman